This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There is one word us radio producers can never seem to let go of. Tape. Our job used to be all about tape. My first Moran's recorder captured sound on cassette tapes. If you're a little bit older than me, you even produced your stories on tape. You'd sit in front of a reel to reel and cut apart someone's voice with a razor blade and then splice the magnetic tape back together with clear adhesive tape.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。有一个词，我们广播制作人似乎永远无法割舍，那就是“磁带”（Tape）。我们的工作曾经完全围绕着磁带展开。我第一台莫兰（Moran）录音机是用卡带录音的。如果你比我年长一点，你甚至还用磁带制作过节目。你得坐在开盘录音机前，用剃须刀片剪开某人的声音，然后再用透明胶带把磁带接起来。
These days we use digital recorders and computers, but we still use the word tape. If Sam or Katie or Avery goes out and does an interview, the first question I'll ask is, did you get good tape? The raw material that we work with is tape, it just is. There is no alternative. The story we're presenting today is about one artist who is also inextricably linked to tape. Cassette tapes, in this case, had it not been for obsessive fans collecting and copying and passing along his songs in the era of tapes, we might never have come to know his music. Then again, had he lived in a different era. Perhaps he would have gotten the recognition he deserved
如今我们使用数字录音机和电脑，但我们依然沿用“磁带”这个词。如果萨姆（Sam）、凯蒂（Katie）或艾弗里（Avery）出去做采访，我问的第一个问题总是：“你录到好的磁带了吗？”我们处理的原材料就是磁带，事实就是如此，别无选择。我们今天讲述的故事是关于一位与磁带有着千丝万缕联系的艺术家。在这个案例中，是卡式磁带。如果不是那个磁带时代里那些痴迷的粉丝们收集、翻录并传播他的歌曲，我们可能永远不会认识他的音乐。话又说回来，如果他生活在另一个时代，也许他生前就能获得他应得的认可。
within his own lifetime. From radio producer Charles Mayans, this is three records from Sundown. You know, one of the things that I've said a lot, but I'm not sure how much people understand it really, I don't like singer songwriters generally. It's not what I choose to listen to Roots music or to jazz or to, you know, music by, I don't want to exaggerate this, but, you know, music by real people, by people from the earth, people who are not middle class, you know. And I don't think in history you look back, I don't think there's that many examples of the middle class inventing anything, you know, culturally.
在他有生之年。来自广播制作人查尔斯·马扬斯（Charles Mayans），这是《日落后的三张唱片》（Three Records from Sundown）。你知道，我常说一句话，但我不太确定人们是否真正理解，我通常不喜欢创作歌手。这不是我选择去听的音乐，我喜欢根源音乐、爵士乐，或者，你知道，由真正的人创作的音乐，来自大地的人，不是中产阶级的人。我不认为回顾历史，中产阶级在文化上发明了什么东西的例子有很多。
So when I put on a tape and I hear, you know, well educated white person strumming a guitar. You know, I'm looking at my watch and I'm saying, okay, I'll give this about another 15 seconds. And then, you know, unless the voice is really startling. And Nick Drake just grabbed me by the throat. And it's one of the great sadness and frustrations of my life in the music business that I wasn't able to figure out a way to get it across to people in his lifetime. Three records from sundown. The early days. In 1966, Joe Boyd, an ambitious young American, arrived to London hoping to make his mark in the thriving music scene. He produces the first Pink Floyd single,
所以当我放上一盘磁带，听到一个受过良好教育的白人在弹吉他时，我会看着手表说：“好吧，我再给它15秒。”除非那个声音真的很惊人。而尼克·德雷克（Nick Drake）一下子就抓住了我的喉咙。在音乐行业，我人生中最大的遗憾和挫折之一，就是没能在他有生之年想出办法让人们了解他。《日落后的三张唱片》。早期。1966年，乔·博伊德（Joe Boyd），一位雄心勃勃的年轻美国人，来到伦敦，希望在繁荣的音乐界留下自己的印记。他制作了平克·弗洛伊德（Pink Floyd）的第一张单曲，
and he discovers the English folk rock pioneers to fairport conventions. But arguably, he makes his greatest find, far from the streets of London, in Cambridge, with Nick Drake. The English have such funny names for class. I would call him an upper middle class boy. The upper middle class always call themselves middle class.
并发现了英国民谣摇滚先驱费尔波特公约乐队（Fairport Convention）。但可以说，他最伟大的发现是在远离伦敦街道的剑桥，那就是尼克·德雷克。英国人对阶级有这么多有趣的称呼。我会称他为一个中上阶层的男孩。中上阶层总是自称中产阶级。
But the lower middle class also call themselves middle class. Anyway, he was definitely going to a boarding school. He spoke with a very refined accent. He was part of a kind of gilded youth generation of well-off upper middle-class kids. And he was very talented in music. He started playing the clarinet, he switched to the guitar, his mother played the piano and wrote songs. And years later I discovered I heard tapes of his mother and they're amazing. You know they have these wonderful chords
但下中产阶级也自称中产阶级。总之，他肯定是要去寄宿学校的。他说话带着非常优雅的口音。他是那种富裕的中上阶层孩子组成的“镀金青年”一代的一部分。他在音乐方面非常有天赋。他开始弹单簧管，后来转弹吉他，他母亲弹钢琴并写歌。多年后我发现了，我听了他母亲的磁带，非常棒。你知道，它们有这些美妙的和弦，
in the piano. And you know the style of the song is a bit, you know, very English, very, almost music hall, but upper-class music hall, flanders and swan and roll-coward and kind of thing. And he started playing the guitar. He was just, I don't know where it came from, but he developed a way of reproducing the guitar, the kind of chords that his mother played on piano. I heard him first because one of the Ferepor Convention told me about hearing him at a concert and the roundhouse. It was a Vietnam protest concert. And I followed up the lead and invited him to come in and bring me a tape. He brought me a tape. And I put it on at the end of that day and just immediately knew that this was something completely different.
在钢琴上。你知道那种歌曲风格有点，你知道，非常英式，非常接近音乐厅风格，但那是上流社会的音乐厅，像弗兰德斯和斯旺（Flanders and Swann）以及诺埃尔·考沃德（Noel Coward）那种风格。他开始弹吉他。我不知道他是从哪儿学来的，但他发展出一种在吉他上重现他母亲在钢琴上弹奏的那种和弦的方法。我第一次听说他，是因为费尔波特公约乐队的一位成员告诉我，他在圆屋剧场（Roundhouse）的一场音乐会上听过他演奏。那是一场反越战音乐会。我顺藤摸瓜，邀请他过来带一盘磁带给我。他带给我一盘磁带。我在那天结束时放了它，立刻就知道这完全是不同的东西。
A lot of retuning of strings so that he played in very unusual tunings. And his articulation of arpeggios on the guitar and the whole way he used the guitar to underpin his songs is completely unique in my view. It's so strong and so central and so devoid of solos. I mean there's nothing about guitar solos in there. It's just a way of orchestrating a song in a complexity that is staggering. stagnant. It's from the city, down to the cave. It's such a master, it's such a sleep. The boy immediately signs Nick Drake to a deal with his witch season imprint on island records. The year is 1968, Drake is 20 years old. But boy's new talent is beyond reticent. His memoirs,
他重新调弦，所以他用非常不寻常的调弦方式演奏。在我看来，他在吉他上对琶音的诠释，以及他利用吉他来支撑歌曲的整个方式都是独一无二的。它如此有力、如此核心，且完全没有独奏。我是说，里面根本没有吉他独奏。这只是一种以惊人的复杂性来编排歌曲的方式。它是从城市到洞穴。他真是位大师，真是个睡美人。博伊德立即与尼克·德雷克签下合约，将其纳入他岛屿唱片（Island Records）旗下的“女巫季节”（Witchseason）厂牌。那一年是1968年，德雷克20岁。但博伊德这位新天才极其沉默寡言。他的回忆录，
quote rights. In the years to come, I would get used to Nick Drake's way of answering the telephone. As if it never rang before. Here comes the story. He was so shy as a performer when the circumstances were right and the only of the circumstances that I remember most clearly as being right was when the federal convention played the festival hall and it was very dramatic because they'd had a car accident and the drummer had been killed and this was a reconfiguration of the group so everybody was in their seats and respectful.
引用道：“在未来的岁月里，我习惯了尼克·德雷克接电话的方式。就好像电话从未响过一样。”故事来了。作为表演者，他非常害羞，只有在特定情况下才表现得好。我记得最清楚的情况是费尔波特公约乐队在节日大厅（Festival Hall）演出时，那次非常戏剧性，因为他们遭遇了车祸，鼓手去世了，这是乐队的重组，所以每个人都坐在座位上，表现得很尊重。
Nick came out, didn't say anything, played a song, he'd be applauded, and then spent three minutes without speaking, retuning his guitar. Everybody stayed silent. He played again, everybody gave him a big ovation. We got an own court at the end. And I thought, this is gonna work. And then you send him out on his own,
尼克走出来，什么也没说，弹了一首歌，他得到了掌声，然后花了三分钟一言不发地重新调他的吉他。每个人都保持沉默。他又弹了一遍，每个人都给了他热烈的欢呼。最后我们还返场了一次。我想，这行得通。然后你让他独自一人去演出，
you know, and there's a student union, a full of kids, and there's a bar at the back. He doesn't say anything. He doesn't know jokes. He has no way of chanting. He just took returns to his guitar and takes quite some time. And he just, in those little intervals between songs, he lost everybody. And until we really stopped performing live and there was no other way in England in those days to really break an artist.
你知道，那是一个挤满孩子的学生会，后面有个酒吧。他什么也不说。他不会讲笑话。他没有任何互动方式。他只是回到他的吉他前，花了不少时间。在歌曲之间的那些小间隙里，他失去了所有观众。直到我们真正停止现场表演，而在那时的英国，没有其他方式能真正捧红一位艺术家。
The Middle Days. At this point, all efforts to advance Drake's career would center on the recording studio. Boyd Recruit's engineer John Wood at Sound Technique Studio in London for Drake's debut album. The record is called Five Leaves Left. The year is 1969. It's difficult to remember that there wasn't really a template for doing this kind of record in those days.
中期。此时，所有提升德雷克事业的努力都集中在录音室。博伊德为德雷克的首张专辑招募了伦敦声音技术录音室（Sound Techniques Studio）的工程师约翰·伍德（John Wood）。这张唱片叫《Five Leaves Left》。那一年是1969年。很难想象，在那个年代，制作这种唱片并没有真正的模板。
To record a singer with strings or with a larger orchestral arrangement, but not in a pop way, with a kind of dry-ish sentiment sound on the voice and doing it in a sort of tasteful way. It was not something that had been done much. And we'd already tried one arranger, the guy who worked on the James Taylor record, the first James Taylor record, and just hated what he did with Nick's song. Just didn't work at all. And Nick then said, well, I have this friend in Cambridge, Robert Kirby. And I went up to Cambridge to meet Kirby. And I was a bit freaked out because I thought Nick
录制一位带有弦乐或大型管弦乐编排的歌手，但不是以流行的方式，而是让嗓音带有一种干涩的情感，并以一种有品位的方式来做。这并不是一件常做的事。我们已经尝试过一位编曲人，就是为詹姆斯·泰勒（James Taylor）第一张唱片工作的那个人，但我非常讨厌他对尼克歌曲的处理。根本行不通。然后尼克说，好吧，我在剑桥有个朋友，罗伯特·柯比（Robert Kirby）。我去了剑桥见柯比。我有点抓狂，因为我觉得尼克
is world class. So we want the best. We want the top arranger in London, whoever it is, we'll spend the money. We'll get the guy. And Nick was saying, well, actually, let's try my friend in Cambridge. He's 19 years old, you know. And I think, oh, no, no, no, you know.
是世界级的。所以我们想要最好的。我们想要伦敦顶尖的编曲人，不管是谁，我们会花钱。我们会请那个人。而尼克却说，好吧，其实，试试我在剑桥的朋友吧。他才19岁，你知道。我想，哦，不，不，不，你知道。
But I went up and met him. And I just liked the way they worked together and the way I liked Robert. And he seemed to really, really love Nick and his music. And I just felt, okay, let's just go with this. And so he did this first session, and the first track they did was Way to Blue, which I had never heard, because he didn't have a way to play it to me, in a way.
但我还是去了并见了他。我只是喜欢他们一起工作的方式，我也喜欢罗伯特。他看起来真的很爱尼克和他的音乐。我只是觉得，好吧，就用他吧。于是他做了第一次录音，他们做的第一首歌是《Way to Blue》，我以前从未听过，因为他没法以某种方式放给我听。
And I suppose I could have gone down into the room and just listened, but I tended to, you know, let John would be the guy running around moving microphones and messing around in the studio and I sat in the control room. And besides, it was a climb, you know, this control was upstairs and you had to climb all the way down and all the way back up again. So I was just sitting up there reading my paper
我想我本可以走进房间去听，但我倾向于，你知道，让约翰·伍德去负责移动麦克风和在录音室里忙活，而我坐在控制室里。而且，那得爬楼梯，你知道，控制室在楼上，你得爬下去再爬上来。所以我只是坐在上面读报纸，
and listening to the restraings rehearse. And you'd hear them, John, would focus on one microphone, then another microphone, then another microphone, trying to get that in, he'd go downstairs, move the microphone, move the chairs around. I kept hearing these bits and pieces of this thing, I just sounded amazing, I couldn't figure out what it really did sound like. And then finally, we got everybody in position and John got his sound he wanted on every microphone, every part of this six-piece string ensemble. And then he
听着弦乐手们排练。你会听到他们，约翰会专注于一个麦克风，然后另一个，再一个，试图得到那个声音，他会下楼，移动麦克风，挪动椅子。我一直听到这些零碎的声音，听起来太棒了，我无法想象它听起来到底是什么样。最后，我们让每个人都就位，约翰在每个麦克风、这六人弦乐合奏的每个部分都得到了他想要的声音。然后他
just pushed all the faders up. And we listened to this whole thing and I just don't know. A way to find the sun Tell me all that you need Show me what you love to share Once you come and say If you're all the way to me. I thought when we made the record, oh my God, the critics are going to love this. This is so, but we're going to get headlines. You know, Melody Maker said that it was an awkward mixture of folk and cocktail I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
推起了所有的推子。我们听了整首歌，我不知道。我想当我们制作这张唱片时，哦天哪，评论家们会喜欢这个的。这太……但我们会上头条的。你知道，《Melody Maker》说这是一种民谣和鸡尾酒的尴尬混合。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. The record sells fewer than 5,000 copies. Boyd is discouraged, but Drake is distraught. Seeking to build on what Little Momentum exists, Boyd or just Drake back distraught. Seeking to build on what little momentum exists, the boy just drag back into the studio. This would produce his second record, the album brighter later, the year is 1970. One of the things that influenced my approach to make a lot was the first
对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。这张唱片销量不到5000张。博伊德感到气馁，但德雷克心烦意乱。为了利用仅存的一点势头，博伊德把德雷克拉回录音室。这产生了第二张唱片，专辑《Bryter Layter》，那一年是1970年。影响我制作《Bryter Layter》的方法之一是第一张
Leonard Cohen album, which I thought John Simon did a great job of producing. And one of the songs I love was So Long Mary Anne. And he has these girls mocking his line, sort of singing behind him against him in a kind of contrast in their brassiness to his delicacy. And when he played me poor boy, originally when he played it to me, that chorus line, oh poor boy, so sorry for himself. He sang that. And I said, I just had this idea right away, and she said, Nick, let's get some girls singing to sing that line. You answer at the end of them. Beginning of the chorus, you pick it up to the end of the chorus.
莱昂纳德·科恩（Leonard Cohen）的专辑，我认为约翰·西蒙（John Simon）制作得非常棒。我最喜欢的歌之一是《So Long, Marianne》。他有那些女孩嘲弄他的歌词，在他身后或与他对抗着唱，她们的泼辣与他的细腻形成了一种对比。当他第一次给我弹《Poor Boy》时，那句副歌“Oh poor boy, so sorry for himself”，他唱了那句。我立刻有了个主意，我说：“尼克，我们找些女孩来唱那句吧。”你在她们后面回应。在副歌开始时，你一直唱到副歌结束。
It kind of looked to me funny like, are you sure? I said, yes, I'm sure. OK. So sound and I learned recording it very quickly that you just turn neck off in the monitors. Because an X performance is always great. You know, when we would record neck with strings or rhythm section or whatever, even if it was out in the room and when he recorded with strings he recorded in the room and this is different from what people do today. It tracks like River Man.
他看起来觉得很有趣，问：“你确定吗？”我说：“是的，我确定。”好的。所以声音和我很快学会了录音时，你只需要在监听器里关掉尼克。因为尼克的表现总是很棒。你知道，当我们用弦乐或节奏组录制尼克时，即使是在房间里，当他与弦乐一起录音时，他是在房间里录的，这与今天人们的做法不同。像《River Man》这样的曲目。
That's not an overdub string section. You know, that's Nick singing and playing guitar in the room in the middle of the strings. So you're listening very carefully to everybody else. And you go for their performance. But if you get a great take from strings, or the brass, or rhythm section, or whoever the weakest link is, that's your turn. You don't even have to listen to Nick.
那不是后期配音的弦乐部分。你知道，那是尼克在弦乐中间唱歌和弹吉他。所以你非常仔细地听其他人的表现。你追求他们的表现。但如果你从弦乐、铜管、节奏组或任何最薄弱的环节得到了很棒的录音，那就是你的收获。你甚至不需要听尼克。
Then you listen back, and you put Nick in, and it just sends me text. Because he was always just fine. It's those complicated guitar parts. He never flubbed them. He just never did. Oh, I'll be come and go Oh, I'll be come and go Despite critical acclaim, writer later sells poorly. The spare Drake leaves London to move home with his parents in Timworth and Arden. His behavior is increasingly erratic and reclusive.
然后你回听，把尼克加进去，这简直让我震撼。因为他总是表现得很好。那些复杂的吉他部分，他从不弹错。他从来没有。尽管受到评论界的好评，《Bryter Layter》销量依然惨淡。心灰意冷的德雷克离开伦敦，搬回了位于坦沃斯因阿登（Tanworth-in-Arden）的父母家中。他的行为变得越来越古怪和孤僻。
At his family's urgent, Drake seeks psychiatric care. Detail. Around the same time, Boyd leaves London for California, where he accepts a job in the film industry. Nick Drake has a kind of reputation as a very solitary lonely figure. What was it like Oda's with the person you knew? Yeah, I mean he was soft-spoken, he was hesitant, but he knew what he liked and he was at very good ideas and he worked very closely with Robert Kirby and it was incredible fun to work in the studio with Nick just because the material you're working with is so great.
在家人的催促下，德雷克寻求了精神科治疗。细节。大约在同一时间，博伊德离开伦敦前往加州，接受了一份电影行业的工作。尼克·德雷克有一种非常孤独、寂寞的形象。作为你认识的人，他是什么样的？是的，我是说他说话轻声细语，犹豫不决，但他知道自己喜欢什么，他有很多很好的想法，他与罗伯特·柯比合作非常紧密，和尼克在录音室工作非常有趣，仅仅因为你处理的素材太棒了。
And the fact that it's not a self-contained group, you've got to go out and put a group together to make these records one track at a time. The End Days In 1972 Drake records his third and final album Pink Moon. The record consists mostly of just voiced guitar and Drake does not as boy to participate. Pink Moon sells fewer copies than even its predecessors. Soon thereafter Drake suffers a mental breakdown in his hospitalized. Falling is released, Drake and Boyd agreed to new work on a new album. That album has never finished.
而且事实是，这不是一个自给自足的乐队，你必须出去组建一个乐队，一次一首曲目地制作这些唱片。末期。1972年，德雷克录制了他的第三张也是最后一张专辑《Pink Moon》。这张唱片大部分只是人声和吉他，德雷克没有要求博伊德参与。《Pink Moon》的销量甚至比前几张还要少。此后不久，德雷克精神崩溃并住院。在《Pink Moon》发行后，德雷克和博伊德同意合作一张新专辑。那张专辑从未完成。
In 1974, Drink has found dead in his bedroom. Due to an overdose in the antidepressant, tripped his own. He was 26 years old. Good-hey. Nobody knows. So I written and I saw you say I've been the moon as I've been say And I know you stand so tall You're a bingo moon, and I get you on the plane Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
1974年，德雷克被发现死在卧室里。死于抗抑郁药物过量。他年仅26岁。
Is that the end of the story? No. Detail. Boyd eventually sells his label's stake in island records. One of his parting conditions is that Drake's recordings never go out of print. Never? Never. A second detail.
这是故事的结局吗？不。细节。博伊德最终卖掉了他在岛屿唱片公司的股份。他离职的条件之一是德雷克的录音永远不能绝版。永远？永远。第二个细节。
After his death, Drake's recordings begin to find an audience. Fans make pilgrimages to the Drake family home in Timworth and Arden. Drake's parents, Rodney and Molly, touched by the interest in their son, invite these visitors in and allow them to copy cassettes and home recordings of Drake's music. Over time, the Drake legend spreads. A combination of word of mouth and tape to tape. To tape. To tape.
他去世后，德雷克的录音开始找到听众。粉丝们前往坦沃斯因阿登的德雷克家朝圣。德雷克的父母罗德尼（Rodney）和莫莉（Molly）被人们对他儿子的兴趣所感动，邀请这些访客进来，并允许他们翻录德雷克音乐的卡带和家庭录音。随着时间的推移，德雷克的传奇传播开来。口口相传与磁带翻录的结合。磁带。磁带。
To tape. To tape. To tape. To tape. To tape. To tape. To tape. Is it surprising to you how popular Nick Drake's music has become kind of after his death and sort of that, called Sprung Brown?
磁带。磁带。磁带。磁带。磁带。磁带。磁带。尼克·德雷克的音乐在他去世后变得如此受欢迎，这让你感到惊讶吗？
No, I mean, I always thought he should be that popular and my view was what took everybody so long. It's such a shame that people didn't recognize it in his lifetime. But, you know, there it deem me so high. You know, I don't know how to deal with questions like it was ahead of its time, because I don't think so, it was very much, you know, it happened in that time and it was a set of influences that, you know. But I do think that, in a way, it's failure at the time has been part of its success now, in the sense that very few people growing up in the 80s,
不，我是说，我一直认为他应该那么受欢迎，我的观点是为什么花了大家这么久。人们在他有生之年没有认可他，真是太遗憾了。但是，你知道，这对我评价很高。你知道，我不知道该如何处理“他超越了时代”这样的问题，因为我不这么认为，他非常，你知道，他发生在那段时期，这是一系列影响的结果，你知道。但我确实认为，在某种程度上，他当时的失败成就了现在的成功，因为很少有在80年代成长起来的人，
they didn't have parents who were playing Nick Drake to death at them. There's no films from the 60s with girls dancing around with flowers in their hair. A wist-naked rake has the soundtrack. I mean, it's not identified with that period. It is culturally unanchored. So it's free to be adapted and embraced by people from other generations and people, you know, just to come upon it.
他们的父母没有把尼克·德雷克的歌放给他们听。没有60年代的电影里有女孩戴着花在头发里跳舞，而尼克·德雷克是配乐。我是说，它没有与那个时期挂钩。它在文化上是无根的。所以它可以自由地被其他世代的人改编和拥抱，人们，你知道，只是偶然发现了它。
It doesn't sort of say that I am from the 60s. You know, it just says on a drink. Please, give me a second grace. Please, give me a second face. Falling for a heart our first time around I'll wait to sit on the ground in your way So come, come right in my streetcar by the bay For now, I must know how I will find you Are in your way, I must see your eyes She was I But she won't need to cry
它不会说“我来自60年代”。你知道，它只是说“我是尼克·德雷克”。
For it's ready to work For the flight nd 1.5% 2.5% 2.5% 2.5% 2.5% 2.5% 2.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5- 3 records from sundown was produced by Charles Mayans in 2009. It received a third-coast festival director's choice award in that same year.
《日落后的三张唱片》由查尔斯·马扬斯于2009年制作。同年，它获得了第三海岸电影节（Third Coast Festival）导演选择奖。
99% invisible is Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery Trouffleman, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced at the offices of Arksign and Architecture firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, Tumblr, Spotify, we're all on Twitter, but our true home online is 999PI.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《99% Invisible》的成员有萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Trouffleman）和我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在加州美丽的奥克兰市中心，建筑公司Arksign的办公室里制作。你可以在Facebook、Tumblr、Spotify上找到并关注这个节目，我们也在Twitter上，但我们真正的在线家园是99PI.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。